alors richard dans la série confessions
d'un bar geos 8 et u favorable au
divorce
je me suis interdit d'y penser
j'aime j'aime l'idée qu'un couple aille
loin au sens je me sens à l'avortement
ouais
ce que j'entends toujours des gens dire
commun à l'avortement mais c'est ok je
comprends l'idée de vinh san il ya des
gens qui se retrouvent dans des
situations absolument infernal où dieu
même du dollar au à toute sa miséricorde
faudrait peut-être lui demander la nuit
plutôt que de demander à ses serviteurs
à la peine de mort non même pour les
assassins d'enfants
bah oui je suis obligé continue à la
légalisation des drogues douces
ouais ça c'est un vaste débat j'ai connu
certaines l'égalisation à londres dans
les années 60
amsterdam en hollande on connaît aussi
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est quand même tient
autour des lycées des petites écoles est
quand même
maxime ton foulard et qui rôdent quoi et
que j'ai pas envie d'un ghost on de là
dedans feront ce qu'ils voudront coach y
seront au moment où on peut dire oui ou
non pourrait en penser une chose tuer
peu aux contres en fait je sais pas
qu'elles sont et abou dabous tabou tabou
ce qui me choque
à vrai dire un toulouse
moi même je me choque si chaque camp
quand je suis chaud quand tu es choquant
quand je suis un des sens orgueilleux
vanille que 32 toile en ces moments là
ouais moins en moins comme ça moi je
trouve ouais mais y'a encore du boulot à
faire
déjà fait pas mal ouais c'est bon est ce
que tu crois en dieu a je crois en
l'esprit on te croit aux choses qui
vibre croire à la serrure divine oui je
crois au diable bah oui je crois aussi à
l'autre je crois je crois à la mauvaise
enfin il doit y avoir un diable
sympathique et bien diable parfaitement
tordu session donc je crois au diable
sympathique mais je crois aussi au
diable complète le temps du y'a qu'à
voir les événements il faut bien qu'ils
diab qui soit dans cette affaire là
parce que donc le diable ouais je crois
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus